any feelings still there I think
watching back the break-up always makes
me a little bit emotional
but ultimately he didn't feel the same
way I did and I want somebody to feel
this the same way about me as I feel
about them and so for me there's been
Tom and he wasn't my person and so I
think he's a great guy and I want the
best for him and I want the best for me
too so no and not in that way not not in
love with him not in love with him any I
was falling in love with him that I
wasn't in love yeah you told his mom you
were yeah oh yeah I know I'm weird but
not that weird okay so you never said I
look I was confused by that because then
we saw you tell him I'm falling in yeah
yeah I had feelings of like feelings of
progress and I think I have to say I
fell for you so hard because you had
that job in the beginning but the last
couple episodes I was just like Hannah B
has had this comeback story I love
watching I love listening to it was so
much fun to watch I have to ask
does that make you consider being
Bachelorette are you in talks about
maybe being God sure I'm not gonna say
that but I will say that I would love to
have the opportunity because I did
evolve so much as a person on the show
like I came in so terrified of what this
thing was and if I wanted to be
vulnerable with producers with the girls
with Holton and then by the end of it I
mean that I laid it all out on the table
I freaking roared I roared but then I
also was hanabi's hanabi's and I also
was Jimmy
about how I felt and I truly did want
the end of it to be me and it wasn't but
I was still straight stay true to myself
and about everybody be kind of see every
part of me the good and the bad and I
would love to have the opportunity to
continue on shedding that layer of just
trying to be whatever I think people
want me to be and just being myself and
I think I really believe in and be in
love and find your person so if it could
be me that would be great and I'm really
sincere about I think it'd be damn
entertaining I can guarantee that
[Applause]
[Music]